it has been a week of people talking
about episode three of The Last of Us
and now that episode 4 is aired it's
gonna be another week of people talking
about episode three but since I well I
just work here let's talk about episode
four episode four it's like it's the
episode where someone was like oh people
might be too optimistic for Humanity
like they might not think everyone sucks
no no they need to know that people
still suck but at the very least Ellie
needs to learn that I feel like it's
every episode this is the conversation
hey can we do this and Joel's like no we
can't oh because infected no worse
humans I have to give leniency to Ellie
though she grew up in a time where she
never worked customer service or retail
she doesn't know how shitty people can
get but this is the episode we figured
was coming which was hurt person in the
street and Joel's like he ain't even
hurt tries to drive through him and then
firefight a little disappointed in the
firefight maybe it's because in a video
game a scenario like that draws itself
out it feels like there are more enemies
you gotta fight than Joel had to fight
in this episode numerically pretty sure
there were more than three people I had
to put down in that scenario although I
was thinking dude we are four episodes
deep into this show and no one's been
bludgeoned to death with the brick
that's what an iconic Last of Us thing
why hasn't that happened this episode
would have been a good time for that but
you know it didn't it's the thing that
happens a lot in this show scenarios
where again it's gameplay based in the
game it's an action game you're gonna
run into a lot of resistance you do see
Joel and Ellie bonding in this episode
you know as the episodes go on you see a
bit more bonding this was definitely the
episode of bad jokes and puns some of
them are actually pretty good I don't
care those were I was like Ellie those
are solid dad jokes you're throwing out
there I like it there's a special place
in the echelon of bonding and likability
that rests the dad joke so I can always
appreciate it but you just see Joel when
he interacts with Ellie it's actually a
very subtle thing it's just in the way
Pedro Pascal you know he has a glance a
look a reaction a reaction shot you can
tell he's just he's a little more like
all right this kid's all right I can't
tell her that you know because I gotta
be like hardcore but yeah she's cool I
did appreciate the fact something I
noticed in the earlier episode I was
like there's some Trigger Discipline
going on here I do appreciate that when
Joel was teaching Ellie like all right
because that's what I was like I was
like dude Ellie snuck a gun and even
when Joel found out about it he took the
gun back it's going to happen again and
you're living in that world you might as
well teach her so I was like all right
hold it like this finger up the trigger
it seems to be a conscious effort in
this show to have triggered discipline
because a lot of shows and movies it's
all like hands in the air hence right
now I mean it's getting itchy it's all
well and good until he accidentally
shoot someone you don't want to do that
get another two decades ass deep into
the apocalypse people are still watching
coleon Noir videos so like I was doing
Hickok45 you see the new one also before
the Swift [__] of demonetization hits me
this is an airsoft gun it's not real
YouTube even then as an airsoft gun has
been broken since the bush years so
there's that but aside from the
subtleties of the bonding growing
between Ellie and Joel I found it
interesting that he passed the buck of
blame when it came to the guy dying he
saw Ellie blaming herself and he was
like it's not your fault it's mine makes
him a better man than I I'd have been
like it's not your fault it's that
[__] [__] acting like he's hurt in
the middle of the street I mean what a
dick that was a total tactic I know
these things have you ever done that how
about that weather today but there's
still room for Ellie to blame herself
Joel probably knew that and he was like
well it's my fault better me than you
then at the end of the episode they
crashed they sleep in this room in this
building Joel's putting glass on the
ground so no one can sneak up on him and
Sam and Henry uh sneak up on them
meaning Sam and Henry goes down a bit
differently that one's neither here nor
there it's totally fine it's like Oh
either Joel gets jumped when he comes
through the window or they sneak up on
him when they're sleeping
either it's fine it's fine there's a
group of dicks looking for Sam and Henry
you spend a little time with them I
never need that stuff you know I'm
always like that's that's time that
could be dedicated to Joel and Ellie but
I totally get in a world where it's not
a game you want to expand the world make
it feel lived in in the end this to me
was the episode of The Last of Us where
I'm starting to feel complacent you know
the whole mind-blowing wow this is
actually really well put together in
those first two episodes that's
subsiding I feel like this was a shorter
episode than well let's see only had a
computer in my pocket which I could
check oh is that computer in your pocket
you happy to see that oh that is Last of
Us dad joke quality right there good job
Jeremy yeah it looks like it was
slightly shorter than episode two so
it's one of the shorter episodes this is
the kind of episode I describe is fine
it's enjoyable I already like the
characters you don't have to impress me
with that so anytime I get with them I
do appreciate and I have a good time
with but I feel like more should have
happened it's probably because I'm
impressed with the hour and a half long
episodes of The Last of Us or anything
that's not an hour and a half I feel
like it's just cut short variable could
be that and could have gone for some
more iconic brain bashing with bricks
but all in all fine all right so the
Last of Us episode four what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]